he said because you're gonna lose me but
here [ __ ] you and then of course the
guys like a sex bit and there's like
look Bo PETA and give a [ __ ] about a sex
offender getting beat to death so the
guys might think it he might be thinking
we probably won't kill me yeah but
you're gonna lose an eye if I start
hitting you with a [ __ ] you're asleep
and I start hitting you with a lock
you're gonna lose an eye and you're
gonna get shipped in I'm gonna break
your nose and I mean it's it's it's
vicious and you know what's really funny
is like you have guys that are like
owners of banks being told what to do by
crackheads so you got some little
crackhead who comes like um listen ah I
noticed the other day you you had your
your coke on the next to the computer
and you're not allowed to have that it's
a second time and if I have to address
you again then I'm gonna address you in
the morning meaning I'm gonna pull you
up and uh you know you're like I'm a
[ __ ] CEO of a bank I cheat on my
taxes you've got a prison GED the [ __ ]
is how did I get here how is this guy
telling me how to live my life yeah I
mean [ __ ] crazy yes
hilarious so the hope everybody's read
the book is like that's kind of justice
rush morally [ __ ] crow yeah oh listen
you've you imagine my ego being told I'm
so [ __ ] guy come up to me and say Cox
can I talk to you like yeah what's up
they're like listen Brody I noticed the
other day your bed you don't do the
hospital corner and you know you're
supposed to do that I might what are you
joking and they're like no I know it
sounds funny but you know I mean I'm
just bringing it to your attention you
know and there are certain keywords like
do you have a minute
which is basically they're saying
they're gonna confront level you like I
want to discuss so that's the first step
you have to confront level someone if
they don't correct the behavior you get
to pull them up well you have to pull
people up to graduate the program mm-hmm
so they're always looking over a zone
they're always looking for something
Danny I noticed that your shirt is it
exactly it's not been ironed recently
and you know here in our tap we hold
ourselves to a higher standard I just
want to bring it to your attention and
right then you know right then that does
not teach you how to be normal no this
is
listen it's a completely [ __ ] up Pro
let me tell you one thing you know I got
one for you one time a guy is talking to
this chick he's been talking to her for
like a year or so he's telling her I'm
getting out I got no money I got no
money he convinces her to send him money
so when I get out I have money I got a
couple grand 3 grand on my books so when
I get out I'll half three wins I and
he's been doing getting her descending
money
well the deep the drug treatment
specialist start listening to his phone
calls and they hear him telling her that
they come to bring her in the what are
you doing well I mean I I need money and
this and that yeah but don't you have a
girlfriend well I mean yeah I got a
girlfriend well you're not being honest
honesty is the it's the key - oh yeah -
change it's the foundation so you got to
send that money back oh no huh yeah the
three yeah send the money
oh that they'll write they'll have guys
write a letter home to their family and
they have their family write a letter
back that they then read and the the
letter is how did your how did your
loved one hurt your family hurt you how
did his drug and alcohol or in criminal
behavior harm you so you got guys that
are getting letters and then they're
reading it in group therapy sessions and
if your mom writes a letter about what
your crimes have done to her and how she
feels about you she's never told you
this yeah and it's read in front of the
20 guys that are in your group therapy
you've got guys gangsters crying like
small [ __ ] children weeping because
mom just told everybody have you've
embarrassed them how you're just a
scumbag how they're they're humiliated
by your behavior how I mean you got guys
that are just listen it's there there's
a lot of stuff they do that will [ __ ]
you up
and guys do some guys are irrevocably
changed by that program and some guys
are just faking their way through it but
the book everybody I swear the book is
like bro it's [ __ ] amazing they're
like I'm laughing one minute and then
when this happened brought was in
[ __ ] tears you know - bro this the
doctor that runs the program there
her name is dr. Smith bro that she for
some reason the second time I went in
she like took interest in me
she starts bringing me in all the time
asking about my son my son my ex-wife my
mom my dad you have a son yeah bro
listen it got so bad I was like Pavlov's
dog walking to the office I start
tearing up because I know [ __ ] she's
gonna ask this she's gonna talk about
this she's gonna and I mean I'm just
there are certain things like I'm like a
complete sociopath on certain aspects
and there's maybe three four things you
could ask me about that I'll immediately
start crying like a [ __ ] child is
your son one of them my son would be one
of them which we're not gonna talk about
oh you're talking about that in the
podcast I assure you we're not gonna
talk about it it's like it horrible
maybe that means it is yeah we should
know I think we should listen I will
beat you to death with this heavy
[ __ ] thing my two friends will
definitely help take you man who's gonna
drop some money in the chat I mean Matt
will wrestle right here on top of this
table for the right price how much it
gets depends on how nasty again I mean
what you were talking about is really
interesting like that program to help
heal people the crabs here the crabs
here like that criminal sociopath brain
don't you're able to fake your way
through anything so how can they like
call you out on you like upholding your
truth and not just being a complete
sociopath criminal and saying what you
need to to get through it how I mean
here's the the problem is that well it's
like mmm here's here's why I think and a
lot of people to go through the program
and they know he's faked in he built dr.
Smith think in mind she's seen a
thousand Matt Cox's she's seen on mm
this guy five that she emit as soon as
you walk in she's categorized
he's got a part this personality type
he's got this he's got this but as
you're sitting there you sit down as
she's talking to you she can sit there
and go okay so one of your parents has
an alcohol problem is that right and
you're like never had a conversation
with you but within three or four
minutes she's already listen I remember
I used to say I feel horrible for her
her husband or her ex-husband cuz he's
never won an argument
guarantee you can't win an argument with
this chick she could just like stare at
you oh my god twist this twist that one
of those I would walk in there and
immediately I felt like the room was
closing in I'm the only time I've ever
had a conversation with someone the
whole time I'm sitting there I'm
thinking how can I get out of the room
how can I get out of the room how can I
get out of the room even before you're
in the room like you were talking like
she's just in your head that much to
where you know the things that she's
gonna ask right so she would and there
were people will people be people
graduating the program and she'll know
he faked his way through the program he
didn't really this it but he did
everything was supposed to do he went to
the things I can't really change that
he's gonna get us he's gonna get the
year often he's gonna move forward and
there are other guys that she knows this
guy has irrevocably been changed and I
think he's a better person as a result
of of the program and listen there that
honestly that type of a program should
be done throughout the Bo P like to
knock off times because guys are
genuinely trying to learn the material
it's the first time you can see guys
that they're really trying someone were
like oh I'm faking it I'm faking it yeah
you're faking it bro but I seen you
crying like a baby
in the in the morning meaning Realty
right so you can sit here and tell all
your gangster buddies are faking it but
the truth is when they read that letter
from your mom or your grandmother mm-hmm
you weren't faking it so you can tell
they they do change some people do
change and maybe they change temporarily
but I think it's a good way to help
retrain how people think and criminals
there's really there are programs but
the programs are pretty much a joke
mm-hmm and you can't really expect these
guys to go out of their way and try and
change when they don't think they have
an issue but if you gave them an
incentive you said look you pass this
nine-month program and you get a year
off they're gonna try it's gonna lower
recidivism for sure mm-hmm
but but you know it's a limited program
but ia ought to do it across
the board like they ought to say you get
20% off your sentence if you pass this
program and do like oh man you really
see some changes I think stuff like that
is super important too because you know
you reach a certain point and that sort
of pattern and thinking to where you
don't even recognize the way that you're
thinking like that anymore and then it
just like brings attention to it well
that's all folks you get over it in that
nine months that when they they teach
you to do these certain things you have
to take workshops and all kinds of you
have to go through our essays and where
the votes the other thing is your God
there's two different types I forget the
other one I actually in the book I have
my they're not our essays their attitude
checks
I have attitude checks throughout the
book so you actually get to read my
attitude checks all of an attitude check
it's like you know today I was in the
chow hall and the guys were standing in
front of me they were screaming and
hollering and being disrespectful and
but you know but you can't get away from
screaming hollering it and all I could
think about was hitting one of these
guys in the head with a baseball bat you
know and so you're sitting there
thinking you know it was everything I
could do to tell him to shut the [ __ ] up
you know and then you go attitude check
you said what was what attitude was I
struggling with humility and then you
say you know then you say you know I had
to tell myself that you know they
weren't raised in the same type of
environment and to them they didn't
there they didn't realize that what they
were doing was being rude he said what
attitude was I you know what attitude
was I you know was I displaying and then
you say whatever it was humility or you
know giving or forget I don't know what
the [ __ ] and then you say if I continue
this behavior or they're practicing
these types of self you know talk or
whatever then I'll be able to deal with
you know these complete jerk-offs that
scream and holler and spit in people's
faces you know yeah you know you you
kind of you talk your way through it
instead of being like a bro you want to
keep your [ __ ] mouth you want to be
disrespected well you got to be just you
know is that next thing you know you're
in a confrontation right that's a way of
processing these emotions that you're
not used to processing other than
dealing with it you just like rob rage
right right and here's the thing is that
it's funny because the some of the guys
that have the hardest time are guys that
why
the smarter guys that have smarter
crimes that you would think would sail
through they do sail through they sail
through the first second third phase and
by like the fourth phase or is it the
third phase I forget just before you
graduate when they really expect you to
show some emotional changes that's when
they tear guys like like I don't know
that I would have graduated the program
because that last phase they destroy me
that's what they really call you and get
you right that's worth because and
that's and so graduating the program I'm
probably could have maybe I could have
graduated MIT it would have been hell it
would have been me and tears four to
three months straight I can't do i dry
the jus the year yeah I'll do the extra
that's emotionally taxing too yeah
especially if you've never felt those
emotions for that long like a year I'm
just staying within yourself rather than
a couple of months of sharing with
everybody that year sounds pretty good
yeah put your crabs here and that sounds
pretty good too
[Laughter]